i'd go through the thought experiment of
i like
thinking about clones
uh
like twins twins are clones basically
basically but
um the ability to generate i mean you're
stuck with the those cl
the twins is a fixed number of clones so
that's a genetic clone i mean a
philosophical clone where you can keep
generating them versions and then i the
reason
i really like that construction thinking
about that like for me personally is
it
nicely encapsulates how i feel about
being human because why do i matter if
i'm
how would i if i do another copy of me
how would i defend
why i matter as a human being and i
don't think i can because that clone if
it's just fine
it's a not even a perfect like a
reasonable clone like most people i know
um that love me and who i love they'll
be just fine with the corner
they'd be like and some they'll be
surprised like
you're like
your move kind of weird but like overall
but otherwise i'll take it and if that's
possible to do that kind of copying
and no i don't want to say perfect one
because i think perfect alone is very
difficult engineering wise i mean like a
pretty crappy copy would still be okay
just like wears
suits a lot
has a weird way of talking i mean i
think there's a lot of elements there
like uh you know in the in the digital
space especially with the metaverse
you can clone i think you know in the
next few decades you'll be able to clone
people's behavioral patterns uh pretty
well
and visual uh
at least in the
in the virtual reality in the digital
representation if you are and then you
have to really contend with like why do
i matter is maybe what matters isn't the
individual person but what matters are
the ideas that that person plays with
um so it doesn't matter if there's a
thousand clones what matters is that i'm
currently thinking about
x or some kind of problem that i'm
trying to solve and those ideas and i'm
sharing those ideas maybe ideas of the
organisms and not the
the meat vehicles of the organism maybe
that's a cultural shift where we won't
necessarily treat any one body as
fundamentally
um
unique or important but the sort of
the ideas that those bodies play with i
mean that sounds crazy no it's
absolutely abstract but very well derek
parfute wrote this great book called
reasons and persons about
how you really define an individual is
not just your own thoughts and your own
self reflection but
we're almost he argues more defined by
how other people have seen you see like
if you walked out into the world and say
suddenly nobody knew who you were
recognized you you would be in some
regards deceased really if no one if
everyone just suddenly had massive
amnesia and you just didn't know who you
are and never remember no memory of
anything you'd ever done together
you'd be very alone you'd be basically
you know starting from scratch because
you've just been born basically so and
also you write thought experiments like
what if half of your neurons get
replaced with half of someone else or a
quarter or 60 at what point do you stop
being you and become that other person
and the argument he makes is it's more
than just what percentage of your
neurons are swapped out it's also the
relationships you have with so many
people that partly define you no not
completely but they're a key component
of how you view yourself how they view
what you are in the world
and you know and he actually goes so far
to say
that they're probably you know more
important than even what's in your head
like if you swap out you know all of
your thoughts but when you walk out into
the world everyone still treats to you
and talks you the same way as this
memory of what you are that is like an
entity that's defined you even if all of
your
you know there's even movies like
trading spaces about this with eddie
murphy like these are people who can
swap bodies
er the reason those are comedy is
because they're fish out of water
comedies and but but they go to the
point of what defines you is not just
you but also your viewed well you as an
entity exist in the memories of other of
other beings and so
that yeah the the
the entities
as they exist in their form in those
memories perhaps are more important
to who you are than what's in your head
and that clones then
are um
how do they do they lessen
not really they just distribute they
just scale the uness that can be
experienced by other humans like if i
could be doing five podcasts right now
at the same time then theory but i'd
have to have some way to transmit the
memory of which one i did
which would be hard but not impossible
if it's all digital you could aggregate
and accrete more and more of the
memories in the one entity oh i see but
i thought at the at the moment of
cloning it's like cloning a git
repository then you're no longer is
branched you share
you share the version view one of chris
that a lot of people have experienced
like your high school friends college
friends colleagues and so on but now you
moved on to your music career and one of
your clones did yeah right and then that
that's fundamentally new experiences
that you you still
um your colleagues can still experience
the memories of the old christmas but
the new one
is totally you're going to have new
communities experiencing connecting to
those and then you can just propagate
and the ones that are don't get a lot of
likes on social media we can we can
like quietly dispose of we want to
maximize is the clones of chris that can
uh get a lot of likes on facebook